on va voir ça justement à butcher on va
retrouver du leader crâne notre
correspondant gulliver bonjour antonio
goûter rsa donc fait cette déclaration
depuis boudhha où vous vous trouvez
justement
oui je suis devant le site de l'un des
fosses communes qui a été découvert dans
la région ici dans le centre de boue de
chasser lundi 6 dans la région de kiev
quand tony woodley a visité le maire de
bouche à anatolie fedoruk était ici
aussi et il a dit qu'il estime que ces
visites antonio coutelis mais aussi
d'autres leaders de pays et de figures
de la scène internationale il y avait le
premier ministre bulgare en fait qui est
ici juste après monsieur gautier baisse
pour le mérite de boudhha c'est très
important symboliquement parce que
d'après lui cela montre que ce n'est pas
juste une lutte entre l'ukraine et la
russie mais une lutte ce sont les mots
du maire de boudhha de du monde civilisé
contre la russie et donc je pense que de
ce point de vue là cette visite a été
assez bien reçu et je vous rappelle
aussi que anthony gonzalez
il a aussi dit que ce ne sont pas les
rencontres qui vont mettre fin à cette
guerre c'est la russie qui va mettre fin
à cette guerre qu'on la russie va
décider d'arrêter de tirer donc en ce
sens je pense que les ukrainiens peuvent
penser qu'il est assez aussi il est allé
aussi loin qu'il pouvait realistic mans
dans sa rhétorique antonio guterres est
ce qui a aussi dénoncé tout à l'heure
l'absurdité d'une guerre au 21ème siècle
oui et là je suis d'accord avec gauthier
rybinski qu il dit la paix c'est bien la
guerre c'est mauvais et que ce n'est pas
vraiment quelque chose qui peut changer
malheureusement la situation sur le
terrain en ukraine la perception en
ukraine c'est que le pays n'a pas
vraiment le choix que de faire la guerre
parce que la russie a des ambitions
affichées d'un excès tout un pan du
territoire ukrainien sinon des décapités
le leadership de l'ukraine et donc de
priver le pays de son indépendance et
réellement en ukraine les appelle comme
ça à la paix ce sont juste des mots qui
peuvent être jolie et bien sûr dans un
monde idéal il n'y aurait pas la guerre
mais vite qu'avant ce moment l'ukraine
n'a absolument pas le choix que de
continuer la lutte contre contre la
russie et elle espère qu'elle va
continuer à avoir le soutien de ses
alliés occidentaux dans cette lutte
merci beaucoup giver craag en direct de
boue de chat en ukraine dans la banlieue
de qui